und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne Gellinek
guten Abend die Geschichte um den
mysteriösen über den USA fliegenden
Ballon geht weiter am Abend hat ein
us-militärflugzeug das mutmaßliche
spionageobjekt aus China wo der Küste
von South Carolina abgeschossen den
Befehl dazu erteilte Präsident beiden
daran Hassan Sade berichtet
seit Tagen lag Präsident beidens Problem
im reinen Wortsinne in der Luft ein
mutmaßlicher Spionage Balance aus China
der Druck auf die US-Regierung wuchs mit
jeder Stunde in der der Balance durch
den Luftraum der USA schwebte
am Mittwoch als ich über den Ballon
informiert wurde gab ich dem Pentagon
den Befehl ihn abzuschießen so schnell
wie möglich
sie entschieden der beste Zeitpunkt sei
wenn er über Wasser Fliege um niemanden
am Boden zu verletzten sie haben ihn
erfolgreich abgeschossen
ein amerikanischer Kampfjet hat den
Ballon abgeschossen gewartet hat das
US-Militär um keine Menschen durch
herabstürzende Teile zu gefährden der
Balance zerfetzt und die amerikanische
chinesischen Beziehungen befinden sich
wohl in einer Zerreißprobe
der Ballon hat der Welt noch einmal die
explosive Rivalität der beiden
Supermächte vor Augen geführt und daran
erinnert dass China seine Großmacht
Ambitionen unbeirrt weiter verfolgt Teil
der Strategie des chinesischen
Präsidenten ist die Wiedervereinigung
Chinas mit Taiwan zur Not auch mit
Gewalt die Menschen dort fürchten sich
sie glauben dass China jetzt wo die Welt
mit dem Ukraine Krieg beschäftigt ist
Fakten schaffen könnte und bereiten sich
vor Elisabeth Schmidt berichtet
kenne und erkenne deinen Feind
Jungtier schon weiß genau wie
chinesische Soldaten Uniformen aussehen
sie hängen in seinem Waffengeschäft
mitten in Taipei 15 Jahre war er Soldat
in einer taiwanesischen Eliteeinheit
heute produziert er Maschinengewehre
Pistolen und andere softairaffen
originalgetreu nachgebaut doch die
Munition ist aus Plastik Schirm
trainiert Zivilisten Schießübungen für
den Ernstfall
aber wenn man nicht vorbereitet ist wenn
er wirklich passiert dann kann man ihn
nicht überleben vielleicht können wir
China nicht alleine besiegen aber wir
können Sie glauben lassen dass wir so
stark sind dass sie ein hohen Preis für
einen Angriff zahlen müssen
erst Mitte der Woche drangen laut
taiwanesischen Streitkräften 34
chinesische Militärjets in Taiwans
Luftraum ein 9 Kriegsschiffe kam
bedrohlich nahe Ziel Taiwans
Verteidigung zu zermürben
ist ein Inselstaat und wenn es zum Krieg
kommt wird Taiwan im Grunde blockiert so
dass es sehr schwierig ist Waffen und
Munition aus dem Ausland nach Taiwan zu
liefern Taiwan befindet sich also in
einer viel schwierigeren Lage als die
Ukraine wenn es um Kämpfe geht wichtig
ist also dass wir unser eigenes Land
selbst retten können
im Dezember beschloss Taiwans
Präsidentin den Wehrdienst von vier auf
12 Monate auszuweiten die
Wehrpflichtigen sollen unter anderem den
Einsatz von Flugabwehrraketen trainieren
Umfragen zufolge unterstützen zwei
Drittel der Menschen in Taiwan diese
Reform
vier Monate Wehrpflicht waren angesichts
der Spannungen zwischen China und uns
ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen zu wenig
das reduziert die Kriegsgefahr wenn wir
mehr trainieren dann sind wir nicht mehr
das alte Taiwan wir werden stärker dann
werden sie uns nicht mehr angreifen
Hoffnung liegt auch auf dem großen
Verbündeten den USA Washington baut
seine Stützpunkte im Südpazifik aus
diese Woche erst ein neues Abkommen mit
den Philippinen China kritisierte es als
einen Akt der den Frieden in der Region
gefährde
das ist natürlich ein gefährliches Spiel
es ist auch damit zu rechnen dass
beispielsweise aus den USA wiederum eine
hochrangige politische Delegation in den
nächsten Monaten in thaiway landen
könnte also insofern
bei aller Hoffnung auf eine Stabilität
dort muss glaube ich mit einer
Eskalation gerechnet werden
wann genau sei noch nicht entschieden
sagt der Forscher in Taipei ist schon
immer wachsam Leben mit der Kriegsgefahr
für ihn ist das zum Alltag geworden
im ukrainekrieg gab es heute einen
winzigen Lichtblick Moskau und Kiew
tauschten erneut Kriegsgefangene aus
nach Angaben aus der Ukraine kehrten 116
Soldaten und freiwillige zurück das
russische Verteidigungsministerium
sprach von 63 freigelassenen
der Gefangenenaustausch der unter
Vermittlung der Vereinigten Arabischen
Emirate zustande kam ist der einzige
Gesprächsfaden den es noch gibt zwischen
den Kriegsparteien darüber hinaus
sprechen nur noch Waffen was das
bedeutet schildert unsere Reporterin
Kathrin Eigendorf
an der Frontlinie nicht einmal einen
Kilometer von der russischen Grenze
entfernt wir sind unterwegs mit einer
Einheit der ukrainischen
Territorialverteidigung nur in ihrer
Begleitung können wir uns hier aufhalten
sie beschießen uns hier ständig gerade
hat man mich benachrichtigt dass eine
orlandrohne in der Luft ist die führt
Aufklärungsflüge durch normalerweise
beginnt dann eine Stunde später der
Beschuss deswegen ist es gefährlich wir
bleiben kurz dann gehen wir in den
Bunker
der Kommandant will mir gerade die
letzten Raketen zeigen die hier
einschlugen da geht es los
wir müssen schnell in den Schützengraben
unter der Erde warten wir während
draußen Artillerie Feuer zu hören ist
und die anderen Männer sind Zivilisten
sie haben sich freiwillig gemeldet für
den Einsatz an der Front ihr selbst hat
vor dem Krieg beim Zoll gearbeitet
wir haben nicht genug Waffen hier
westliche Waffen würden uns sehr helfen
Panzer Mörser Artillerie
um uns zu verteidigen
führt mich durch die Schützengräben
einen Labyrinth indem sie immer wieder
Schutz suchen in Stellungen wie diesen
wird der Krieg in der Ukraine auch
entschieden
wir beobachten Sie von hier aus wenn was
ist dann kriegen sie etwas mit diesen
Waffen möchte ich wissen das alte
sowjetische Maschinengewehr ist das
einzige was sie hier haben und es
funktioniert noch
ihor nimmt mich mit in das
Einsatzkommando das in einem ehemaligen
Verwaltungsgebäude im Keller
untergebracht ist von hier aus
beobachten Sie das Gebiet noch im
September hatten sie die russische Armee
von hier zurückgedrängt
wir sind überall auf Position wir
wechseln ständig unsere Standorte die
Russen können unseren Standort
identifizieren und könnten uns treffen
das ist auch schon passiert auch hier am
Ende des Raumes haben sie einen Museum
errichtet mit Waffen und Uniformen die
die russischen Soldaten hinterlassen
haben in einer Halle nebenan haben sie
sogar einen russischen Panzer den sie
erobern konnten gerade wieder
hergerichtet
nun wollen sie ihn an der Frontlinie
einsetzen
denn hier rechnen Sie wie überall im
Land damit dass die Russen bald ihre
Frühjahrsoffensive starten könnten
und wir bleiben beim Thema
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine die
Nachrichten mit Gundula die
Bundesregierung wartet nach ihrer
Entscheidung fürlieferungen von
Kampfpanzern an die Ukraine noch auf
konkrete Beteiligungen von
Partnerstaaten bislang sagte nur
Portugal zu ebenfalls einige Leopard 2
abgeben zu wollen Polen hat unterdessen
mit der Ausbildung ukrainischer Soldaten
an Leopard Panzern begonnen ebenso wie
Großbritannien am Challenger 2
bei der Deutschen Post gehen die
Warnstreiks weiter vor allem in
Nordrhein-Westfalen bleiben viele Briefe
liegen in Essen legten rund 400
Beschäftigte die Arbeit nieder in dem
Tarifkonflikt will Verdi die Warnstreiks
bis Dienstag auf ganz NRW ausweiten die
Gewerkschaft fordert 15% mehr Lohn für
die bundesweit 160.000 Beschäftigten
in Upahl im Nordwesten von Mecklenburg
haben Pläne für eine Unterkunft für bis
zu 400 Asylsuchende heftige Diskussionen
ausgelöst ein Großteil der 500 Einwohner
lehnt das geplante Containerdorf ab aus
Angst vor Kriminalität und wegen der
hohen Zahl der erwarteten Flüchtlinge
unter protestierender Anwohner mischten
sich auch Rechtsextreme
die brasilianische Marine hat ein seit
Monaten umheririn des Schiff einen
ausgemusteten Flugzeugträger im Meer
versenkt die rund 60 Jahre alte Sao
Paulo wurde kontrolliert geflutet 350 km
vor der Küste umweltschütze üben schwere
Kritik das beschädigte Schiff war voller
giftiger Asbestplatten
es sollte einen journalistisches
power-haus entstehen ein crossmedialer
Champion der den großen tech-plattformen
und Streaming-Diensten wie Netflix
Amazon und Google Paroli bieten kann der
Weg dorthin eine Fusion des Senders RTL
mit dem alt ehrwürdigen Verlagshaus
Gronau und ja Bauer sucht Frau trifft
Landlust sozusagen das ist der Plan des
Mutterkonzerns Bertelsmann nun aber
stellt sich heraus dass der Hamburger
traditionsverlag schlecht mit dem Kölner
Privatsender zusammenpasst schon gehen
Gerüchte um RTL wolle Magazine wie
Brigitte Gala und schöner Wohnen
verkaufen oder sie gleich zum Altpapier
geben Martin Niessen berichtet aus
Hamburg
am Hamburger Hauptsitz ist der
renommierte Verlagsnamen längst
verschwunden statt Gruner und Jahr steht
dann nun RTL Deutschland das gleiche
beim Internetauftritt und seit Wochen
wird nun spekuliert rtl-chef Thomas
Raabe wolle den Verlag zerschlagen
Magazine wie beef und Brigitte Gala und
Geo verkaufen die Gerüchte Küche brodelt
was bleibt der muss gehen natürlich
haben alle Sorgen
ja auch wirklich verstehen und das würde
sich auch Herrn Rabe so gehen wenn er in
unserer Situation wäre dass er sorgen
hätte um seinen Job von RTL gibt es
bislang nur eine Dürre Wochen alte
Pressemitteilung man analysiere das
Titel Portfolio Verkaufsgespräche gäbe
es aktuell nicht Hauke hell arbeitet für
die IT-Abteilung des Verlags ihn ärgert
vor allem die mangelnde Transparenz die
Geschichte die uns erzählt wurde die ist
es nicht mehr es ist wohl irgendwas
anderes
Wasser ist weiß keiner es redet ja
niemand mit uns dabei hieß es zusammen
stärker als die zum Bertelsmann Konzern
gehören in Medienhäuser vor rund einem
Jahr fusionierten der trotz
Umsatzrückgang schwarze Zahlen schreibt
eine traditionsverlag und der
Privatsender im Quoten tief gemeinsam
als neuer nationaler Infotainment
Champion so die Idee für viele eine
Schnapsidee ich glaube man hat hier
wirtschaftlichen Interessen den Vorrang
gegeben man hat nicht so sehr auf den
journalistischen Anspruch geschaut und
natürlich lässt sich das was das
Privatfernsehen bei RTL in den letzten
kann man so vorgelegt hat nicht
unbedingt vereinbaren mit den hohen
Ansprüchen die die meisten Titel von
grune und Jahr haben die Gewerkschaften
Verdi und deutscher Journalistenverband
protestierten vor dem Verlagshaus gegen
die vermeintlich einfachste aller
Lösungen Titel verkaufen Arbeitsplätze
abbauen
wir mit Qualitätsjournalismus in Zukunft
Geld verdienen will darf nicht die
Redaktion zusammen kürzen
redaktionsbeiräte appellierten in einem
Brandbrief an die Bertelsmann Eigentümer
an deren unternehmerische
gesellschaftliche und soziale
Verantwortung aber es geht um mehr eine
Zerschlagung des geschichtsträchtigen
Verlages wäre wohl nicht nur für den
Medienstandort Hamburg ein schwerer
Schlag das war immer auf sowas wie ein
Leuchtturm der weit über Hamburg hin
ausgestrahlt hat und insofern ist das
schon etwas was glaube ich nicht nur
Hamburg trifft sondern wenn das so käme
wie manche ist befürchten dann hat das
auch eine Auswirkung glaube ich darauf
wie überhaupt Fall auch Verlagshäuser
geguckt werden wird in Zukunft wie auf
eine Branche geguckt wird nachdem die
schon nicht was ist denn dann mit allen
anderen am Dienstag will rtl-chef Rabe
die 1.500 Mitarbeiter in Hamburg über
den Stand der Dinge informieren und
vielleicht die Frage beantworten was von
Gruner und ja übrig bleibt
der Schauspieler und Regisseur Jürgen
Flimm ist im Alter von 81 Jahren nach
Hamburg gestorben das Thalia Theater der
Hansestadt machte er als Intendant mit
spektakulären Inszenierungen zur
bestbesuchten Bühne Deutschlands zuletzt
war Flim Intendant der Berliner
Staatsoper Bundeskanzler Scholz Berichte
Flim auf Twitter sein großes Herz seine
Zuversicht und sein feiner Humor werden
fehlen
starke Schneefall erhöht in Österreich
die Lawinengefahr bislang kamen drei
Skifahrer ums Leben die abseits der
Pisten unterwegs waren heftige Stürme
erschweren die Arbeit der Rettungskräfte
bringen Bäume und Strommasten zu Fall
allein in Tirol gab es bis jetzt 30
Lawinenabgänge
auch morgen ist mit Schneefall zu
rechnen nächste Woche dann mit viel
Sonnenschein Schnee kommt morgen in
einem Streifen östlich von Weser und
Oberrhein Regen und dichte Wolken von
der Ostsee bis zum Schwarzwald sonst
auch mal Sonne an der Nordsee
stürmischer Nordwind - 2 bis plus 8 Grad
am Montag schneit es noch im Südwesten
ab Dienstag kommt dann überall die Sonne
durch bei -2 bis plus 6 Grad
fehlen noch die gewinnzahlen vom Lotto
sie lauten ohne Gewähr 29 31 33 34 35
37 Superzahl 8 weitere Gewinnzahlen auf
Lotto zdf.de und im ZDF Text
und alles vom Sport jetzt gleich im
Sportstudio mit Dunja Hayali die drei
Hockey Weltmeister zu Gast hat und
direkt danach gibt es hier wieder eine
heute Express einen schönen Abend und
uns gibt's morgen wieder tschüss
[Musik]